[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne crois pas j'ai ma place
on est on est des dingues et je suis là
[Musique]
j'ai acheté plein de lunettes de soleil
sur alex triste on va les voir me voici
en 2040 je sais tout ça alors on dirait
une mouche
[Musique]
des prix si jamais je suis invite à une
soirée l'euphoria star wars ça parce que
c'est une clé pipeau les lunettes échos
vivent
ça c'est parfait barrières on voit rien
on peut regarder bête les gens c'est
parfait ni qu'elle s'y trouvait salut
les copains alors j'espère que vous avez
dit que vous allez bien c'est quoi la
jeune française qu'est ce que vous allez
dire à deux sessions et aucune réplique
tu as ta vraie défiance je suis une
femme d'affaires ou alors je me souviens
que si j'ai vu des migrants au nom aussi
nancy
paris des secrets speaking ferry
narbonne ce mec
mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai oublié mon train si on va demander
à quelqu'un simone est ce que tu peux me
rappeler mon train s'il te plaît mais
bien sûr will you le train à destination
de strasbourg terrain -3 leurs signaux
dépêche-toi le départ est imminent merci
beaucoup c'est mal du coup
qu'est ce que tu penses de ce
commentaire
je sais faire moi dire mais c'est parce
que t'es trop fort je pense que des taux
n'est pas parce que c'est vrai qu'elle
me rappelle dans cette fantaisie